caryl Brookins was a pioneering woman in
the world of finance a former executive
director of the World Bank
she was just over five feet tall but she
could fill a room with her intellect and
her spunk said longtime friend Lawrence
Goodman a Phi Beta Kappa grad of the
University of Oklahoma
Brooklyn started in the bond market in
Chicago in the 70s and rose to vice
president at EF Hutton on Wall Street
before forming her own firm President
George W Bush appointed her to the World
Bank in 2001 she had a passion for
history and for France
- Kimberly Reid head of the
export-import bank Brookins was a mentor
and surrogate mother
I'm gonna miss hearing that voice
helping me guiding me she said she would
always stand up for what was right
Carole Brookins was 76 dr. Chung you key
through was a chemist who led research
and development at BF goodrich born in
Seoul he served in the South Korean army
during the Korean War captured by the
north he escaped and in 1962 came to the
u.s. to study at Wayne State University
in Detroit later his wife and three kids
joined him all became US citizens dr.
rue joined BF goodrich in Brookville
ohio and was awarded numerous patents he
literally wrote the book on toughened
plastics his wife eunsu he met in fourth
grade they were married for 68 years
they were the ultimate love story said
granddaughter Kaitlin Kim they've gone
through so much together his faith and
his family were everything
all of his grandkids went to college
some graduating with advanced degrees
said katelynn I hope he knows that he
inspired a lot of that dr. Chang you key
through was 91 dr. James a Mahoney was a
pulmonologist in the intensive care unit
at SUNY Downstate Medical Center in
Brooklyn
hey guys doing this morning Charlie as
he was called started as a student at
the hospital's teaching college in 1982
and stayed becoming a professor himself
he would bring the best out of you and
he would not give up on you said dr.
Julian Cavanaugh who was his intern
resident and later his colleague he
created footsteps that other minority
doctors can walk in and change things
dr. Mahoney who raised three kids was
contemplating retirement when the corona
virus broke out even after he got sick
he was still calling patients to monitor
them he died in the hospital where he
had worked for nearly 40 years dr. James
Mahoney was 62 Inez Gonzalez was a
corrections officer at the Edgecombe
facility in New York nicknamed momma T
she was the rock of the family said her
niece Jessica Gore fine she always told
me just to help people help as many
people as I can
her wife Rosa was her queen they were
together for 30 years married for 12 and
raised three daughters her family was
her entire life said Ashley gore fine
she would work two jobs just to make
sure they had what they needed
Inez Gonzalez was 55
toran Howard played bass in the family
gospel group the spiritual Souls and
worked as a mental health counselor at
Boys & Girls village in Milford
Connecticut helping at-risk children at
six foot three he was a gentle giant and
just so giving said his girlfriend
Taisha teasley they met a decade ago
this is the type of man she said that
women only dream about and will be high
school he'd been all City tackle on the
football team
he went to Southern Connecticut State
and hoped to pursue a master's in
psychology to work with urban youth then
to have him tragically pass said Taisha
it's just crazy
toran howard was 26